[Music]
so it's been known for quite a while
that ilhan omar apparently married her
own brother to help him gain entry
illegally into the country that's a
violation of immigration law
that actually happened it turns out and
now we're learning the fbi had evidence
to confirm it but didn't do anything
about it
miranda devine is an actual journalist
she works at the new york post or she
writes a column she joins us tonight to
explain what exactly happened miranda
thanks so much for coming on
pleasure tucker we'll add some
basically republican operatives um up in
minnesota decided to spend hundreds of
thousands of dollars on private
investigators to really find out if
ilhan omar was a genetic match the dna
match to the man who was her second
husband
they went to three continents they found
a cigarette butt and a drinking straw
which
they decided they sent it to a dna
laboratory and found conclusively
that the dna matched that the second
husband was a sibling
according to this dna sample so
the the very day that they were going to
unleash this on the world and in fact i
was interviewing one of the people
involved
the fbi swooped on the the gentleman
anton lazzaro from this uh this
republican uh pack up in minnesota
and arrested him on some
different charges uh who knows whether
you know he's guilty or not guilty i
mean he's not guilty until uh proven but
he's in jail and so his story never got
to see the light of day i mean luckily
he'd he'd
told the fbi they were not interested
they told him the statute of limitations
had run out we managed to see the
website before he took it down before he
was arrested and managed to report the
story such as it was
i wonder i just kind of spit on here
what will be more shocking to her fellow
liberals the fact that the fact that
johanna omar had an incestuous marriage
to her own brother or that she smoked
cigarettes which will they be more
stunned by
definitely the latter and they've got
photographs of her smoking the
cigarettes so i don't think that's uh
that's at all in doubt
yeah incest is just a kind of alternate
lifestyle but smoking a cigarette
that's immoral
clear
she did marry her brother we know that
not only repulsive but illegal it's
fraud she's not been indicted she's not
going to be indicted that's totally cool
now
well the fbi was told by one of these
associates of these people that found
the information and was just told no
that the they've just decided the
statute of limitations has run out on
marriage fraud even though there's no
statute of limitations on immigration
fraud
yeah or on smoking cigarettes apparently
random vine great to see tonight thank
you so much
thanks second hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else